[موسيقى]
تشير التقديرات إلى أن البريطانيين يستهلكون
أكثر من 100 مليون كوب من الشاي يوميًا ،
يزعم البعض أنها مفتاح الصحة العقلية الجيدة ،
لكن
لماذا وأثناء تناول هذا الموضوع ،
حتى أننا نصنعه بشكل صحيح ،
هذا هو أفضل متجر في لندن
مشهور عالميًا باختيار الشاي
هنا ، سنقوم بإعداد كوب لطيف
من الشاي الأسود
إذا كنت تريد كوبًا رائعًا من الشاي ،
أقترح أن تفقد أوراق الشاي إذا كنت
تستخدم أكياس الشاي ، فلن يكون لديك مساحة
كافية لتخمير الورقة
بشكل صحيح  من الأشياء
المميزة لعمل الشاي والشاي
أنه لا يمكن القيام به في لحظة ،
وهذه ظاهرة غير شائعة بشكل متزايد في
حياتنا اليومية الحالية
المكون الكيميائي النشط الذي
تم تحديده في أوراق الشاي  هو
الثيانين
مادة كيميائية تعمل على تحسين
موجات ألفا المرتبطة
بالتهدئة والتركيز ، يمكنك استخدام
الماء المغلي ، لكن اترك الماء
يبرد لمدة 30 ثانية
سيكون على ما يرام ، ثم قم فقط
بصب الماء في الداخل.
اعلم أن الإبطاء والقيام
بشيء واحد في كل مرة مفيد لنا كما هو
مطلوب عند صنع كوب من
الشاي الأسود ، يمكنني تحضير ثلاث إلى خمس
دقائق إذا كان الشاي الأخضر على سبيل المثال
دقيقتين وثلاث دقائق يستغرق وقتًا لغلي
الماء
ثم  يجب أن يتخمر الشاي هذه فترة طويلة حقًا
في هذا اليوم وهذا العصر الحالي ، لذا
باستخدام مصفاة
كهذه وتسكب الشاي برفق في الكوب
عندما نشرب الشاي ، نعود إلى
ذكرياتنا السابقة عن شرب الشاي
وعادة ما تكون  مرتبط
بالمشاركة مع محادثة الآخرين
الجاهزة ،
إنه مجرد شيء
غير مؤذٍ ، وهذا النوع من مواد التشحيم الاجتماعية هو
دعوة شخص ما لتناول فنجان من الشاي
لتقديمه
لأنه بالطبع مجرد فعل بسيط هو صنع
فنجان من الشاي للزميل يعني
سأستغرق بعضًا من وقتي
وأستثمر في القيام بشيء من
أجلك ، إنها لحظة من اليقظة
أيضًا حتى تتمكن من الاستمتاع
باللحظة الحالية ، كما أن هناك
احتفاظًا جسديًا بشيء دافئ وهو
أكثر إرضاءً  الإحساس
بدلاً من الاحتفاظ بشيء بارد ، لذا لا يمكن تمييز
الجوانب الاجتماعية والثقافية للشاي عن الجوانب
الكيميائية
[الموسيقى]